Like a city from a children's storybook,....
...Prague conjures up images of romantic fairy tales,...
and when the clouds roll in, dark gothic folk stories.
Yet, it can be refreshingly modern too.
Prague's cobblestone streets rarely follow a straight line.
The city is a labyrinth where even locals get happily lost.
This was a place designed for horse and cart and walking,...
...so pack some comfortable shoes.
An easy way to discover Prague is to follow the Royal Route.
This historic coronation path begins at the Powder Tower,...
...one of the original gateways to Prague's Old Town.
A few blocks away is Old Town Square,...
...a plaza surrounded by former palaces.
Enjoy some traditional street food like trdelnik,...
...then gather with travelers from all over the world...
...under the astronomical clock.
Across the Square is Tyn Church, whose turrets and spires...
...are said to be the inspiration for some of Walt Disney's famous castles.